Tell me about yourself.
Well, I have six and a half years of medical sales experience covering a very large territory...
...to bring to this position.
So, I'm self - motivated and I can work alone.
During that time, I had valuable opportunity...
...to interact with doctors and other medical professionals,...
...whether it was through new product demonstration or in-service training.
Or sometimes I would just drop in so it's more of a cold call situation.
So I'm hardworking and I'm reliable,...
...and I think this really makes me a great asset for your company.
My personality is easygoing, so I get along with most people,...
...and my ability to laugh at myself puts people at ease in tense situations.
I have great communication skills and I'm very comfortable with public speaking.
And I can present complex information in really easy-to-understand ways.
So I think with all of that combined, I really have a lot to offer your company.